okay so this is good I've got a lot of
information here but I feel like I'm
still missing a lot about the overall
shape of this like where am I going to
go in order to work out how my graph is
going to look how the function behaves
I'm gonna need just a teeny bit more
information and there's lots of ways to
do this next part but I'm gonna get us
to use our calculator because it's often
one of the most reliable most people
will find they understand to this
process and it's less theoretical okay
what I'm gonna do is try and understand
as I approach each of the asymptotes
which way am i coming from now I already
know some of this information for
example with the horizontal asymptotes
up here you can see when I approach
positive infinity as I get really large
values of X I know I'm gonna approach
the horizontal asymptote from above okay
so therefore what that tells me is see
here's the horizontal asymptote I'm
going to approach it but I'm gonna do it
from the top side like so okay you can
see if I continue this would go
somewhere up like that okay I don't know
the rest of the information yet but
that'll do for now and I'm just gonna
sort of draw that arrow in as a
guideline in the same way when I'm on
the other side when I'm approaching very
large values of negative x you can see
I'm still gonna approach y equals your
but I'm gonna do it from the bottom I've
got I've got negative values here right
so just like I drew this guideline over
here on the right hand side I can draw
another guideline over here on the left
but I notice it's coming from the bottom
like so
okay now this immediately actually tells
me some information around this that I
can I can work out for example and by
seeing what happens at the asymptotes
that are vertical right what happens
when I get close to those well you can
see and what I've got here is a vertical
asymptote at negative 1 and a vertical
asymptote at 1 so I'm gonna check very
close by on either side what's going on
so to help me I'm actually gonna do it
really quick table values right I'm
gonna say for X is close to negative 1
on the left and then close on the right
so let's try an x value like say
negative one point zero zero one what's
that going to be well it's going to be
very close to this vertical line but
just a little bit further to the left
right and then I want one that's also a
bit close to the rights
what would that look like but still be
close it would be something like
negative 0.999 that would still be very
very close but on the other side of it
okay so you can see x equals negative 1
the asymptotes I don't need to evaluate
that because I know it blows up my
function but these two guys here what
I'm gonna do and I'll copy the arm
definition the function so I have it
closer by what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take this guy and use this to
work out my values okay so I've got my
calculator here so sneaky little thing
you can do is you can save variables
into your calculator using the the store
and recall buttons that you can see here
in on the bottom left hand side of our
virtual buttons on your calculator so if
you don't know how to do that then you
know you can ask one your teachers but
I'm going to take that negative one
point zero one and I'm going to store
that in as as X and then what I'll do is
I'm going to evaluate X plus 2 on x
squared minus 1 for this particular
values so I'm going to go X plus 2 on
the top and then x squared minus 1 on
the bottom and what I get from my Y
value is 499 and some other values of
our decimal values okay in other words
this is a very very large number okay
then when I put in the other one I think
we said it was going to be negative 0.99
so I'm going to take that value there
and again I'm going to store that as one
of my variables so new 0.99 let's store
that one and now I'm going to go and put
it into the numerator in the denominator
I'm just going to do the same
substitution that I did before so it's
going to be X plus 2 on the numerator x
squared minus 1 and the denominator and
I get minus 500 ok now what is this
telling us right you're getting very
very large values right 500 in a
positive direction 500 in the native
direction so what's happening on either
side of this vertical asymptote ears you
have number one for this guy this is a
very large positive value right so
therefore I'm going up like of this okay
that's what
getting just to the left of that
vertical asymptote and then on the
right-hand side or the vertical
asymptote I have very negative large
values like that that was on negative
500 is what I got it drops away off the
bottom okay now I can repeat this
process for the other vertical asymptote
here x equals 1 I can try out values
that are just to the left of that
asymptote and I can try it values just
to the right of that asymptote and just
for the sake of illustration and to
prove the concept when I go ahead and
put it in but this time for positives
instead of negatives 0.99 I'm gonna get
let's see here Wow negative 1,500 for
this guy and then when I go just to the
right with one point or one when I go
ahead and evaluate that you're going to
get I wonder if you can predict what
comes next one point per one I'm getting
1499 and some more decimals actually do
you think it rounds up okay but the
actual value is not what matters it's
where the thing is going so in other
words just on the left so I've got some
of this table happening here right so if
I just draw a big box around their table
table table table just so you can see
the piece of information more clearly
just on the left of X equals one you're
dropping down going dropping like a rock
okay so therefore I'm going to draw this
line going downwards just to the left of
that asymptote and then just through the
right of that asymptote you can see
really large values for Y positively so
therefore your graph is gonna be up here
that's where you're headed so now what I
want you to have a look at I'm gonna
highlight them for you right is I've got
1 2 3 4 5 6 if you like guidelines that
I know have to join up and I should also
mention I have an intercept here at
negative 2 and then another intercept
here and they gave 2 right so now all
that's left is to join the dots ok now
let's go from left to right if I start
over there on the left hand side I know
I've got two from left to right I've got
a go downwards right this is a smooth
graph but I have to sort of come back up
to
or this intercept so therefore what that
means is there's no other choice for
this it has to go down but then it's
going to come back up you can see there
otherwise it would not meet that
intercept and once it goes back up you
can see it actually continues until it
connects with this guide line that we
drew up the top here okay so there's the
left-hand part of the graph what about
this middle section well maybe you can
start to see here in order to clear
these it's less complicated and there's
going to be you know this goes up it
hits your intercept and then it comes
back down it looks a bit like a parabola
right it's not a parabola parabolas have
no asymptotes of any kind but it does
have this kind of arch shape like a like
a concave down parabola okay and then
over here on the right hand side again
it's not to be complicated to fit this
guideline you can see I'm going
downwards and then I have to drop down
until I hit the other guideline and then
off I go and I know this thing looks
weird but that's what you get out of
this rational function it's a strange
beast but once you put together your
intercepts and your asymptotes you get
this shape and you there's nowhere else
you can go now it's worth pointing out I
don't need any points for scale on this
guy unlike our first hyperbola because
you've got both an x intercept over here
and also a y-intercept so you've got a
vertical and a horizontal scale implied
by those coordinates so I'm done